hello everybody my name is markiplier
and on today's show we talk about 3000
subscribers 24 a live street dance
Paisley Steam sale over the first thing
I want to say is that we hit 3000
subscribers that's amazing
3000 that's incredible if you know I've
only been running my new channel for
just a little bit of time so to get
there so quickly I mean less than 2
months to get to 3000 and actually we're
over 3000 we're at 30 to 1 we're well on
our way to 4,000 by now the growth of
the channel is expanding incredible this
far so thank you guys so much for doing
all that you can and my goals have just
been smashed so I've had to push goals
even higher the other thing I wanted to
talk about was the 24 hour livestream it
was a huge success we smashed my goal
once again you guys have proven yourself
better than I ever imagined I already
knew you were good beautiful booth but
you did so much better than I had hope
for we hit the official count on the
chip in widget was 1111 dollars and 11
cents but I know it went higher than
that because at the time when we hit a
thousand I got an email that said wegg
raised 1450 $8 in some odd cents so and
even after we hit a thousand people kept
donating some people donated up to
$1,000 I think in what they were just
talking out there but which may or may
not be true but I don't know I'm gonna
believe them because I have faith in
humanity like that so we probably got
over two thousand dollars donated
child's play in 24 hours which is an
amazing feat you all should be proud of
that I had nothing to do that all I did
was play video games and act like an
idiot most of the night you guys you
guys are the ones that did it you guys
are the one that contributed open your
wallets and we're generous enough that
we were able to reach and exceed and
smash our goal so thank you so much for
that the first thing that I want to talk
about is actually dead space 3 I know we
probably all seen the dead space III
Chandler if you haven't you should go
look it up there'll be a link in the
description below or there may not be
I'm not sure mature women do yet but
anyway there are some headlines floating
around about that's EA said that dead
space 1 & 2 were too scary whoa
well whoa the realization that or games
dead space and dead space 2 are scary
led to the decision to shift the focus
away from scares in Dead Space 3 now
this quote quote has been floating
around the internet for a while now but
it may not be true there is no backing
up evidence that said that EA ever said
this there is no quote to say what
person said this there's not even a
department head or job title that said
that they said this so this may be
entirely fabricated the real quote the
real quote from marketing boss alors
Emile said that we receive feedback to
understand how we can take the game out
to even more consumers now this is from
an EA marketing boss not and not of
visceral Studios representative EA is
not making the game it doesn't have a
hand in the game ea just controls how
its distributed and marketed because
they're the producer that the producing
company not the actual production
company so what does this mean this
means that Dead Space 3 may be just as
scary as Dead Space 1 & 2 which by my
standards weren't that scary but for
most of the people out there
no one's knew it was very scary survival
horror with a little bit action but my
fear is still what I saw with my
eyeballs at the e3 trailer now I want to
point out that in Dead Space 2 they
showed a clip at e3 I believe where
Isaac Clarke was on the train ride over
and it just broke that section off and
he jumped out into the air and used his
rocket boots to scoot his way along to
the next train and all the comments were
whoa calm down there Ironman
you don't need to be going that hard and
everyone thought that Dead Space 2 is
going to be an action game but it proved
to be quite a bit survival horror not as
cramped as Dead Space 1 was so some
people may think that that drops is
scaring this level but still it was very
good like I enjoyed the game and I have
faith in visceral Studios visceral
Studios has earned my respect and being
a maker that a video game production
company that can make good games well
made well put together the mechanics
work and the environment is good so I
believe that visceral Studios will do a
good job with Dead Space 3 however I
believe that he a has it eel hands in
the mix I believe that they are
influencing the game a bit to push more
towards action and why because the quote
said the real quote not the fake you
fricking quote we receive feedback to
understand how we can take the game out
to even more customers and how do you do
that you introduced coop coop inherently
reduces the scariness of any game it's
why left 4 dead 2 and left 4 dead 1 are
not scary game they're first-person
shooters with zombies and that's awesome
I'm sure Dead Space 3 is going to be fun
and I know the Dead Space 3 can be
played in single-player but the game is
built for co-op they didn't create two
different set designs for 1 & 2 the game
is built for co-op you always have to be
wider to accommodate two people the set
pieces have to be bigger to accommodate
two points of view everything has to be
made bigger and more action-oriented
instead of being focused down on scaring
one person now I'm not saying that it's
never going to be scary
I'm sure Dead Space 3 it can be a great
action game with some scary parts
but that's the problem but this is all
way way before the game is actually
released so all of this is speculation
up to this point so I will keep my
opinions to myself you can develop your
own opinions and do whatever you want
that's all I have to say about that
but I have faith at the end of day I
have faith in visceral studios in making
a good game now the final note the Steam
sale is over it's done your wallets can
be put to rest now I don't know what
I've been through a few students summer
sales now like like without ever making
a significant purchase seriously I've
been able to hold back on my wallet
unleashing my wallet on Steam for quite
some time because I just never really
found anything that I wanted to play I
mean all the games there I've already
looked at I've already seen it I'm like
yeah I bought two games on the Steam
sale how about dear Esther because it
was 250 and about sanctum because it was
250 and my friend Plato knows it I spent
five bucks on the summer sale and I'm
seeing horror story the people spending
hundreds and hundreds of dollars did you
guys spend hundreds and hundreds of
dollars let me know because that sounds
outrageous to me why would you just buy
a game if you're never gonna play it why
would you buy a game if you did weren't
even interested in it in the first place
I only buy games that I am very
interested in so you guys need to let me
know about this I mean what's the point
why do you guys feel the impulse to buy
games that you're never gonna play I
want to hear about it and also I hear a
lot of people complaining about how much
they spend the money and I remember very
shortly before the Steam sale started
there was a whole month long period
where where's the Steam sale oh my god
I've got all this money that I just want
to burn and now everyone's like where'd
all my money go I'm sooo sad now and
people just don't think to get that
there's a correlation between the two
I'm pretty sure valve has incredible
marketing insight to build up tension
and then make you unleash ur wallets in
it too
well free of buying so that's all I have
to say about that do you have a comment
about deaths pastry you think it's gonna
be the greatest horror game ever made do
you think that it's going to be the
greatest action game ever made did you
spend a lot of money on the Steam sale
let me know in the comments below so
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye